heavy
for all it went down i thought you and i
be ancient history
don't be a gunk
so what's the latest from clouds know
anything
nothing of any interest got a new
situation
and everybody's trying to adapt me too
doesn't sound like it's all okay doesn't
mean it isn't
any news from the boxes events ideas
no no don't see all that much of them
how come
you know how they are piss me off
sometimes is all
so ready to tell me what we're doing
here
well been tinkering with virtues a lot
lately and figured out a way to scroll
to actors experiences at the same time
thought we could try it out if you're
down of course
how does one marry two separate neural
tracks
well at first i tried to create a single
profile out of two data streams
didn't turn out so great must have
gotten tangled up
interference white noise yeah
effect was kind of like a bad art house
a couple tries in though i managed to
isolate specific sensations
so you load them onto separate neural
tracks
no emo bogeys not bad
sounds like we could do this anywhere
why do we come all the way out of here
what is this place cottage belonged to
someone i knew
it sits empty now i take the liberty to
use it from time to time
and that's where we're gonna scroll
no we're gonna scroll underwater nope
no way bad idea tell her to find some
other yes man
what do you say you in
hell yeah i'm in awesome
so uh let's go got the hardware here
all right suit up land lover
let's get this scroller on
all right let's do this freezing ass
water
here i come
okay we're all set
you go first
where we headed exactly about halfway to
the deepest point it'll be pitch black
but the currents are gentle
ought to be safe want the precise
coordinates
now why bother i'll just stick close to
you
okay
creatures are more to you than just a
way to churn that eddies huh
well duh think paintings
songs they're meant to produce emotion
responses
generally how any kind of creativity
works sure
right so art's a casing trigger for
emotion
will be ds our emotion in near pure form
[Music]
this is it
swim over here and look straight at me
will you
great great signal's clear
just need your help with a few basic
checks need to calibrate our gear
first up motion sensors and scrolling
circle around me swim
[Music]
great motion calibrated back my way now
v
next up sound check i'm gonna hum a song
you give me the title read me
hey i know that edda sorrentino
only you dead on all right that ought to
do it
what now prepare to have your mind
blown wait for it
i grab this and hold on tight
[Music]
down we go
[Music]
impressive huh
that's that's incredible
what is it
just 15 years ago people still lived
here
got some connection to this place right
you got it grew up here
i haven't been back since laguna bend
was wiped off the map
why are you showing me this i want to
get the right
emotional reactions got a feeling this
will be perfect for my experiment
why is this stand to be perfect hoping
you'll be able to pick up
all the unfiltered massive emotions this
place brings out in me
like it or not you'll react to those
feelings that's what i want to capture
sounds nova let's do this coming back
so many times in my head
working up the nerve for this why didn't
you come earlier
good question easy answer would be that
i didn't have time
gear stars weren't ever aligned
truth is the very idea it just felt
weird
so
flow's diner best eatery in town
only one at that too burgers weren't
amazing
too greasy big of course i say that now
back then they were the best thing i'd
ever chewed and swallowed
[Music]
and next door that's where we lived
me and my grandparents just let me know
when you want to forge ahead
[Music]
got something here looks like an old
photo cam
dpi 350 practically an antique
you like it you kidding it's awesome
looks like this fell off your one and
only eatery
let's see now your childhood tasted like
scop dogs from capitan caliente
with abanero sauce extra hot of course
tasted even better place for a friend's
picture
what did they say it ain't caliente if
it don't burn on the way in
nah not much
hockey stick is there a skating rink
here
i wish played street hockey on
rollerblades
they're calling they're calling
[Music]
here take this camera better off in your
hands
sitting here collecting algae gosh
thanks
what about your parents dad was never in
the picture
mom died when i was tiny can barely
remember her
i still have a picture but you know
i see a stranger there
what was that those voices voices
didn't hear anything but you just now
what was it like living with your
grandparents
how were they grandad had a real knack
for things
technical taught me everything i know
and the stories he told never got bored
listening to him
and grandma was temperamental
hot one second coolest
[Music]
let's keep going judy follow me
for anything in particular here no
can't hurt to look around though picking
up very chill
vibes it feels like we're outside of
time
like in a snow globe after that we can
see what lies up ahead
hard to imagine anything that could be
more out of place in an underwater
world hmm bottled water
touched touche
[Music]
gotta say i don't really get why they
left their wheels behind when they had
to evacuate
hey how old do you think i am these
hunks of metal have got
half a century on them when i was about
yeah
they were already here and not in much
better shape
good cover for playing max tack in
psychos though
what this isn't yours
[Music]
so it is it was yours
chapman's
you took her doll as if
hit it was a monster you hit it
why cause i thought only losers played
with dolls
what i really wanted was for her to
notice me
ah the days when dolls were just kids
toys
and nothing else want to see what's
further on
come on man i want to show you something
got no
idea how weird it feels swimming through
here
where you used to run as a kid her
deadly life
grinded along can imagine it a bit
hasn't aged at all always looked old and
like it landed here from outer space
bells were cracked too i gave up this
eerie
[Music]
i don't know how it's possible but i
think i hear those bells too
seriously you can hear my memories
it must be a side effect
ah closed shame
could look for another way inside be my
guest
did you like going to this church never
actually
went to church never even really paid
attention to it it was just
there you know once we knew laguna bend
was to be flooded
people gathered here to plan a protest
did it achieve anything
look around
[Music]
[Music]
i found an opening i think we're safe to
go through
the
here
stuck in here once when no one was
around
stood at the altar and tried to imagine
what went through the body's mind
looking at all those people
back then i wondered how he could read
people's thoughts
know everything about him
then i screamed at the top of my lungs
to check the acoustics
you didn't get chased off ran out myself
[Music]
ah
[Music]
please
oh thank [ __ ] you're alive
how'd you manage to lift me out
don't know didn't think about it i just
did what i had to do
hey careful easy now
so you're saying
you saved my life thank you told you
diving into this
toxic waste was gonna end badly but you
just don't [ __ ] listen
toxic waste is that your construct
you heard him
uh heard's overstating it's just
surfaced in my head a thought that
wasn't mine or completely yours
please just ignore his babbling it's a
complicated relationship why do i even
bother
doubt you should go back to the city
just now
i'm pretty beat too last thing i want to
do is drive
let's stay the night what do you think
why the hell not
whose cottage is that then you said you
knew the owner
one of our neighbors was hell bent on
staying in laguna bend
badges literally dragged him out of his
house before the water came in
so he built himself another house as
close as he possibly could but
then he got sick water was way more
toxic back then
you must be chilled to the bone i'll
brew a pot
how do you take yours
uh black please like the heart of a merc
ah forgot to start the generator
i can turn it on you're gonna take it
easy
promise to take it slow
i think you could have fine-tuned the
emotive wave transmitters better back
there
feet i was picking up felt power's up
what was that couldn't hear you clearly
something to matter
no nothing
don't [ __ ] me judy you're still
synced remember
clouds has gone to [ __ ]
tiger claw no next took revenge for
hiromi and the rest
there was a fire fight tom's dead
roxanne barely got out alive
house closed until further notice
rather not talk or think about it didn't
want to tell you
didn't want you to think i blame you in
any way why would you even assume i'd
think that
no i i'm sorry let's just kill the
subject
i think i'll go lie down
i'm beat
this chick gets online just don't wake
her up
you [ __ ] blow if he can not about to
leave her alone
middle of nowhere no i can't talk to you
when you get this
sentimental waste of words
at least take a nap so we don't have to
argue
will you sit with me or what use your
coffee morning finally
you know yesterday i think i'd made up
my mind
i actually called you because i wanted
to say goodbye
cities chewed me up and spitting me out
look night city's not for everyone
i grew up here thought nothing could
surprise me
and now i'd pack up my [ __ ] and bail too
if i could but
it's just not the right time
give me your handy
all set congrats just gave you unlimited
access to my pad
whoa you're asking me to move in
if it's what you want or just drop by
when the urge grabs you
i don't know what to say nobody's ever
done
anything like this for me it really
shows trust
take care be this really it
last time we see each other didn't seem
so set on leaving just a sec ago
see no reason to delay i'll stay here a
couple
days then head off it's been nice
knowing you've been
see ya and hit me up on the hollow
sometimes
i see you judy
you